so when do you think I'll have this baby
I think the baby's gonna come any minute
yeah the wait is over for Spidey
everyone knows moms go harder
Heidi gave birth to her second child
with hubby Spencer a baby boy making a
big brother out of the couple's
five-year-old son Gunner Gunner is so
excited he kept asking me for a baby
before I got pregnant put a towel down
just in case my water breaks in the car
good ideas
saying that we have at least 10 more
days leading up to their due date The
Hills veterans invited E.T to their
sweet gender reveal party all right the
suspense is killing you guys are you
ready yeah okay all right ready three
two one
[Applause]
[Music]
so what do you think it is a boy or girl
why you're having a brother
are you excited to have a baby brother
I thought it was a girl you did I did I
really did my whole intuition is off I
am big brother
do you have any creative suggestions for
names oh oh my gosh tree is a really
good one
um Colorado
Scorpion and baby number two was no easy
for Mom and Dad so hopefully sooner than
later but it has taken a little longer
than I thought they tried for 18 months
to get pregnant Heidi even went on a
carnivore diet I ate raw organs several
times it really cut out
um almost all processed foods I was
trying to eat hardly any grains and just
trying to eliminate anything that was
causing inflammation I mean I know that
this was a process for you guys to get
pregnant I felt responsible you know I
felt like
like it was like my fault or you know it
was just it was really hard
to feel like you want something so bad
and it's just not
just not possible you know there's
nothing else I could have done the first
trimester was really challenging so I
got really nervous that I was having a
miscarriage and that was really hard
because I didn't experience that with
Gunner thankfully it was a tear near the
baby
um that was okay and was able to repair
itself and staying true to their reality
Roots fans can probably expect a
close-up of their big day ideally we'd
like to have a camera person in the room
obviously we gotta film it someone's
gotta film it I'm makeup artist I
definitely need hair and makeup I gotta
be camera ready so that's two there if
your kids were uh were to grow up and
say that they wanted to do follow Mom
and Dad's footsteps and do reality TV
like what would be your reaction to that
be besides can we be on the show
Good Luck dude you got a camera crew
[Music]
foreign